[Music]
planta Hillsdale was by the best four
years of my life it was team family the
atmosphere was just family coach dick
Lowry came in and that was his first
year when I was his first recruiting
class we won the GLIAC championship in
in 1980 my freshman year it got
hillsdale back on the map for football
and coach preached family and discipline
and character friends I have or like
brothers the most impactful person
besides my father and my mom but it
through the college was coach McEvoy it
was like a second father two weeks in
there my freshman year I you know it
came in I was out of shape I wanted to
go home and coach Mac saw me walking
back to Simpson dorm and said what are
you doing I said I'm going all I have
embarrassed I can't get my equipment and
he never forget he said just remember
that the decision you make today will
impact you and your family for the rest
of your life he said you know the
coaches brought you here because they
had a belief in you you got to find that
inside yourself believe that you can do
it and improve them proven right so one
conversation the coach Mac changed
changed my life started three years was
elected the captain being elected
captain by your teammates was a very
humbling moment you made all-conference
all-district
all-american the signing NFL contract
was was a dream you know I wasn't
fortunate enough to make the final
roster for Detroit of Pittsburgh but I
had two years and in camps and preseason
and I can always look back and say I
tried and I gave it all ahead and and to
me that was good enough the other person
that made a difference in my life was
Keith Audubon our current head football
coach odd I reached out to me and asked
me what what my plans were I didn't
really have any plans I was reeling from
from the loss of my brother Bob and
coach reach out to me and gave me an
opportunity to come up to Ferris become
a coach I coached for four years as a
defense line coach
as a strength coordinator out of reached
out to me at the lowest times in my life
and saved me the thing I miss most about
coaching is how you can influence
somebody's life
I had an opportunity to coach at the
youth level high school college probably
the greatest thing I still get is when I
run into former players and I hear coach
I love it being elected into the hills
of College Athletic Hall of Fame is
unfathomable when I made all-american I
thought that was yeah doesn't get much
better than that you haven't been out of
school for since 1984 you see the people
up I've been back to a couple of Hall of
Fame inductions
and to be considered the best of the
best that I've ever played at Hillsdale
it's it's it's an honor it's hard to
keep putting the word
[Music]
you